كان من المفترض أن أغادر البلاد في
الخامس من مايو ، جاءت والدتي معي
في الصباح ، تناولنا القهوة ، إنها دراجة جيدة ،
لذلك لم أتمكن من رؤيتها
لبضعة أشهر وقمت بتسجيل الوصول وذهبت
إلى ما شابه  ما قبل المغادرة حيث
قاموا بفحص بطاقة الصعود إلى الطائرة
وخرج حوالي 10 من مسؤولي الأمن الإماراتيين
كانوا يرتدونها لكنهم يرتدون الزي المحلي ولكن
أيضًا رجال يرتدون ملابس سوداء وكان لديّ
مسدسات معهم وأخبروني أنه يجب
أن أذهب معهم  لم يؤكدوا أو
ينفيوا ما إذا كنت رهن الاعتقال ، فسألته عما
إذا كان بإمكاني الاستعانة بمحام ، ولم
يسمح لي بمحامٍ قالوا إن
هناك قضية ضدي ، ثم قالوا إنه
لم تكن هناك قضية ضدي ولكن في
جوهري ، كان علي أن أذهب معهم ، ما هي النقطة التي
تم إخبارك بها بشأن التهم الموجهة ضد
التجسس في
نهاية الأسابيع الستة التي
نفذت فيها فترة الاستجواب الأولية ، لكن قيل لي ذلك
لأنني كنت قد اعترفت لأنني
وقعت على كل هذه الوثائق لأنني
ساعدهم في تحقيقهم
أن أسوأ ما يمكن أن يحدث
هو أنني سأُرحل فقط
لأنهم حاولوا وسلاسة العملية ، وقد
جاء هذا من كل من
المحققين والمدعي العام وقالوا ،
اسمعوا أنهم كانوا محظوظين لأنني كنت محظوظًا
لأنني قلت  الحقيقة لأنني إذا
لم أفعل ، فسأكون في السجن لمدة
عشرين عامًا ، وهو ما يثير السخرية في الواقع ،
وهو ما تم اتهامي به لاحقًا
واكتشفت بعض الأشياء التي
أخبرتنا بها الإمارات العربية المتحدة إذا كان بإمكاني وضعها
- واحدة من  هم أنك كنت تستخدم
هويتين مختلفتين لجمع
المعلومات في واحدة كانت ماثيو تحوطات
والباحث الآخر كان ماثيو
تحوطات رجل الأعمال هو هذا صحيح أننا نستخدم
موقعين مختلفين في إجراء
مكالماتك لكنهما كانا نفس الاسم
وكان هناك عدد من الأسطر المختلفة  من العمل
الذي أقوم به ، هذا ما
تعرفه إذا كان بإمكانك القيام ببعض الأعمال
الإضافية ، فقد تقوم ببعض الأعمال الأخرى ،
لكنني كنت ببساطة في UA لإجراء
بحثي للحصول على درجة الدكتوراه ، وقالوا إن
لديك محامٍ  بالإضافة إلى أنهم
يتناقضون مع ما تقوله حول ما
إذا كان المحامي معك أم لا لمساعدتك
في المستندات ، على سبيل المثال ، هذه
كذبة للأسف ، لقد أعطيت محاميًا
للدفاع في جلسة المحكمة التي
حدثت في منتصف إلى أواخر أكتوبر
باستثناء  أنه لم يُسمح لي
بالسماح للمحامي بأي وقت آخر